bonjour à tous l'enlèvement d'un homme
de plusieurs hommes le détournement d'un
avion la séquestration de ses passagers
le chantage au meurtre à la violence
deviennent décidément des méthodes
d'action politique de plus en plus
répandue dans le monde nous venons d'en
avoir encore trois exemples au cours des
dernières 24 heures et par deux fois
cette sorte de chantage a réussi en
grèce d'abord les six membres du
commando palestinien qui avait capturé
hier un avion sur l'aéroport d'athènes
ont pu regagner le caire sans encombre
avec la promesse du gouvernement grec de
libérer dans un mois les sept
palestiniens détenus dans les prisons
d'athènes pour trois attentats commis
depuis le mois de novembre dernier
l'avion des olympic airways la compagnie
d'aristote onassis s'est posé cette nuit
au caire il y avait à bord les six
commandos palestiniens
l'équipage bien sûr et un représentant
de la croix rouge internationale
monsieur andré rochât lesur rocha a
servi d'intermédiaire entre les
autorités grecques et les palestiniens
le suspense sur l'aéroport d'athènes
avait duré huit heures pour sauver la
face le gouvernement grec n'a pas voulu
libérer immédiatement les sept
palestiniens qu'il détient en prison
les deux auteurs de l'attentât du 27
novembre contre les bureaux de la
compagnie israélienne el al attentats
qui avaient fait un mort un enfant de
deux ans et demi ces deux là seront même
jugé presque normalement demain par la
cour d'assises d'athènes mais la grèce
s'est engagée à les grâcier ensuite est
allé remettre le 22 août au plus tard à
la croix rouge internationale comme on
imagine mal que le gouvernement grec
puisse revenir sur cet engagement
eh bien on peut considérer que l'action
du commando palestinien à athènes se
solde par un succès complet et vous en
doutez bien cet état de chose suscite
l'indignation ce matin des journaux
israéliens à jérusalem et à tel-aviv
néanmoins le gouvernement grec on
l'apprend à l'instant ne veux pas avoir
l'air de céder complètement il voudrait
surtout éviter que de tels faits se
reproduisent
il a annoncé que si des terroristes
arabes mener de nouvelles actions sur
son territoire et bien lui le
gouvernement grec qu'il romprait les
relations diplomatiques avec certains
pays arabes
autre affaire du même genre en bolivie
la des guérilleros savez capturé deux
ingénieurs allemands jeunes sous lozère
et gones et relais
ils menaçaient de les mettre à mort si
le gouvernement link bolivien ne faisait
pas libérés immédiatement
dix prisonniers politiques là c'est un
père jésuite de tendance progressiste
qui a servi d'intermédiaire
lady guerriero parmi lesquelles une
jeune fille une étudiante nommée loyola
goodman la voici
on s'est libéré hier soir et conduit en
avion o'shea loyola goodman avait été
arrêté il y a deux ans pour avoir eu des
contacts avec le chef révolutionnaire
d'origine cubaine che guevara comme le
gouvernement grec le gouvernement
bolivien déclare avoir agi par souci
humanitaire et aussi pour préserver ses
bonnes relations avec l'allemagne de
l'ouest mais naturellement tout cela
toutes ces raisons qui sont très
compréhensible ne règle pas le problème
du chantage à la violence
dernier exemple hier soir à edimbourg où
se déroulent les jeux du commonwealth le
coup or noir du kenya
guaino avait reçu des menaces de mort
s'ils participaient aux courses du
cassant et du 5000 mètres vous savez que
le problème racial en grande bretagne
prend des proportions nouvelle qui se
développe et il est probable que c'est
une organisation raciale qui avait
proféré ces menaces de mort à l'égard de
qeynos en tout cas keno n'a pas eu peur
vous le voyez en train de courir l'un à
l'arrivée du quinze 100 m et bien qu une
lettre de menaces est affirmé qu'il
serait tué par un tireur muni d'un fusil
à lunette
dès l'arrivée de la course guaino donc a
couru quand même il a gagné il a fait un
très bon temps sur 400 mètres et il a
reçu la médaille d'or la médaille d'or
des jeux du commonwealth c'est à dire
les pays de l'ancien empire britannique
des mains de la reine elizabeth
elle-même qui elle non plus donc n'a pas
eu peur du fusil à lunette 3,36 et
quelques dixièmes de secondes c'était un
très bon temps l'esprit mais chaîne au
caire nous en comptant les rencontres
leur ont la peur n'a pas coupé les
jambes de qeynos ses affaires assez
dramatique ne sont évidemment pas toute
l'actualité internationale il faut noter
aussi le retour à paris hier soir de
monsieur andré bettencourt ministre
chargé du plan et de l'aménagement du
territoire monsieur bettencourt entre
d'une visite officielle de deux semaines
en chine où il a rencontré le président
mao tsé toung le maréchal link yao qui
est vice président est aussi le premier
ministre monsieur july monsieur
bettencourt a annoncé qu'un membre
important du gouvernement de pékin
peut-être monsieur djouad l'a lui-même
viendrait prochainement en
it en france à une date qui toutefois
n'a pas encore été précisée mon voyage a
dit monsieur bettencourt marque une
nouvelle étape dans les relations franco
chinoises
la crise gouvernementale italienne
d'autre part rebondi monsieur bouillot
andreotti qui avait été pressenti pour
former le gouvernement à renoncer
officiellement ce matin à cette mission
il ne reste plus au président de la
république monsieur eu toutes ces
peyssard agathe qu'à reprendre ses
consultations de faits divers en france
d'abord et toujours le meurtre du
gendarme de colmar la police paraît être
sur une piste grâce au signalement donné
par le gendarme roland meyer qui lui
n'avait été que blessé alors que son
chef le maréchal des logis jardot lui a
été tué le suspect numéro un serait un
repris de justice âgé de 37 ans est
nommée emile kundra depuis le jour du
crime on n'a pas revu à colmar où il a
son domicile et aussi son lieu de
travail pour la première fois les
reporters de notre station de strasbourg
ont pu pénétrer dans la chambre
d'hôpital du gendarme roland meyer et
ils on peut aussi s'entretenir quelques
instants avec lui comment vous
sentez-vous un bien vous parlez
vous pensez pouvoir reconnaître vos
agresseurs la première fois que cela
vous arrive je crois et c'étaient des
hommes et ces ag non merci faut noter
cependant qu'emile coué néral le suspect
que la police recherche n'est encore
qu'à suspect est précisément que les
policiers voletant entendre interrogé à
titre de témoin le juge d'instruction
samson qui est chargé de la faire n'a
pas lancé de mandat contre lui la sphère
boulot c'est le deuxième fait divers est
bien la confrontation organisée hier par
le juge d'instruction a est très très
favorable à ernest beaux lots et à vrai
dire on s'y attendait un peu les divers
interrogatoires des témoins ont fait
apparaître suffisamment d'imprécisions
voir de contradiction entre les
dépositions des divers témoins au point
qu'un des témoins que l'on considérait
comme un témoin à charge le masson josé
nogueira et bien s'est révélée par la
suite être un témoin à décharge en fait
il reste personne n'avait jamais vu
ernest beaux lots mettre le feu quelque
part la liberté provisoire cependant
n'est pas un non lieu cela veut dire que
renaisse de bolo n'est pas
définitivement blanchi vous le voyez ici
et sports la sortie du cabinet du juge
d'instruction
il lui reste maintenant à se faire
innocenter complètement c'est ce qu'il
va s'efforcer d'obtenir avec l'aide de
ses amis et avec l'aide de sa femme que
jean pire lane avait rencontré quelques
instants avant sa mise en liberté
si monsieur bolo et libéré ce soir ou
demain ce que vous comptez rester ici ou
est ce que finalement vous avez
peut-être peur et c'est une des raisons
pour laquelle on attend peut-être
également par qu'être peur que des gens
passablement excité viennent
créer des complications pas de chez vous
si monsieur borloo libre je ne sais pas
du tout je veux pas décider pour lui ça
dépend de ce qu'il veut lui ça dépend
tout ce que je fais maintenant c'est mon
mari tout parce qu'il n'a rien à [ __ ]
draguignan tenez moi mon mari vient elle
l'a eue ce qu on le lui a rendu vous le
savez maintenant
l'enquète elle continue mais il faut
signaler que deux spécialistes de la
lutte contre les incendies de forêt ont
déclaré hier office instruction qu à
leur avis le feu pouvaient être ses
pouvait s'être déclarés spontanément
dans la forêt varoise en raison de
l'écrasante chaleur qui régnait la
semaine dernière sur cette région et en
raison de l'existence de certaines
espèces qui dégazent des essences
volatiles c'est à dire facilement
inflammable dans la forêt le conseil des
ministres en france a adopté hier après
midi une série de mesures concernant la
sécurité sociale vous le savez
certainement mais je crois françois cau
qu'il faut revenir un peu sur ces
mesures c'est donc à vous de nous les
présenter avec l'aide de quelques tables
nous allons effectivement revenir sur
ces mesures avec des tableaux le premier
tableau concernera les allocations
familiales à enlèvement générale de 4
50% comme chaque année interviendra le
1er août mais en outre une augmentation
spéciale est prévue pour les 4e et les
3e enfant
en voilà le résultat pour la région
parisienne salaire unique
il s'agit du revenu fiscal c'est à dire
que 4000 francs correspondent à un
salaire brut de 5300 francs par mois
orphelin cette allocation toute nouvelle
coûtera 300 millions de francs personnes
âgées
ainsi le 31 décembre 1971
chaque personnage et disposera d'un
minimum vieillesse de 10 francs par jour
alors d'autres mesures ont été prises
concernant notamment les médecins ou les
pharmaciens ainsi pour ces derniers la
marge bénéficiaire va être réduite de 1
52% et 2000 médicament peut susciter il
est vrai ne seront plus remboursés par
la sécurité sociale il faut également
ajouter la création de quinze mille
nouvelles places dans les crèches une
aide accrue pour les handicapés
physiques une allocation pour les veuves
et sait bien quelles sont les premières
réactions des organisations syndicales
et professionnelles à ces diverses
mesures elles sont vives
seul de la fédération nationale des
syndicats pharmaceutiques par exemple
qui parle d' une atteinte intolérable à
l'économie des pharmacies d'officine et
menace de manifestations pour la semaine
prochaine
je dis ça parce qu'on a réduit leur
marge bénéficiaire de 1 52% c'est cela
tesla dans les centrales syndicales les
réserves sont également profonde et
sévère de la cftc la cgt en passant par
fo et la cfdt cette organisation entre
autres par le même de bricolage ses
réserves tourne autour d'un thème
identique sur le détail assurent les
syndicalistes on enregistre sans doute
quelques améliorations encore que ces
améliorations sont loin de ce qui leur
était indispensable de réaliser mais sur
le fond c'est à dire sur le plan de la
réforme ce n'est pas avec une telle
politique que l'on pourra résoudre les
problèmes de la sécurité sociale aucune
solution n'est possible sans la mise en
place d'une véritable politique de la
santé oms reste les familles
c'est-à-dire le l'union nationale des
associations familiales
oui leurs dirigeants affirment les vrais
problèmes demeurent sans solution est le
plus intéressant sauf
enfin une dernière question les cadres
sont satisfaits puisque on n'a pas des
flaps phone est complètement leurs
cotisations sociales
ils sont satisfaits le disent néanmoins
sur un plan plus général il assure les
mesures décidées ne constituent que des
expédients voilà oui ce n'est pas facile
et que l'on n'a pas fini de parler de la
sécurité sociale oui à propos de mesures
sociales vous souvenez peut-être aussi
que la semaine dernière le ministère de
la santé publique avait fait promulguer
une nouvelle loi qui rendait obligatoire
la délivrance d'un certificat de santé
après des examens médicaux préventifs
pour les enfants de moins de 6
ce certificat sera désormais nécessaire
pour toucher les allocations familiales
et la prime de salaire unique comme
cette nouvelle mesure a pu paraître à
certaines familles comme une
complication supplémentaire
le secrétaire d'état à l'action sociale
mademoiselle marie madeleine dié naish a
voulu vous donner quelques explications
complémentaires
cette nouvelle loi a pour objet de
découvrir très tôt les maladies graves
les infirmités les anomalies dans le
développement de l'enfant parce que nous
nous sommes aperçus que très souvent les
familles n'étant pas informé ne peuvent
pas savoir les premières infirmité qu'on
l'enfant ils ne peuvent pas le voir et
ce qui fait que même à l'âge scolaire on
voit des enfants qui ne voit pas bien
qui n'entendent pas bien et on s'en
aperçoit que très tard il faut donc s'en
apercevoir très tôt pour pouvoir soigner
l'enfant ou remédier alors à son
infirmité
voilà l'objet de cette loi je crois que
maintenant il ya des sanctions pour les
parents qui ne présentent pas leurs
enfants à cette visite oui nous avons
beaucoup de d'examen où les ans où les
parents doivent présenter les enfants et
nous sommes aperçus quelques fois ya de
la négligence on oublie alors il fallait
une sanction qui les oblige à venir
montrer leurs enfants ou appeler le
médecin pour qu'il fasse cet examen
alors d'ailleurs cette sanction n'a rien
d'extraordinaire c'est exactement comme
pour l'école si l'enfant ne va pas à
l'école on ne fait pas les allocations
familiales
si l'enfant ne subit pas des examens de
santé oms ne paierait pas les
allocations familiales
mais je vous le dis très vite ça ne se
prolonge avait très loin au bout de
quelques jours les parents comprennent
très bien que c'est un simple oubli de
leur parent et l'enfant dans super suaad
et sera montré au médecin soit du centre
de pmi soin aux médecins de famille
assez récente de protection maternelle
et infantile soit aux médecins de
famille et ainsi cela ira pour l'enfant
sera vraiment une quelque chose de très
important pour lui
nous allons faire deux au troisième mois
et au 30e moi parce que ce sont des âges
où on peut déjà commencer à voir si
l'enfant à ses infirmités à ces manques
de développement et l'on peut déjà
soigné et en soignant tout de suite on
peut je le dis quelquefois beaucoup
remédier et même quelquefois guérir deux
jeunes filles de 21 et 22 ans sont tués
hier après-midi au codm escalade dans le
massif de
l'oisans en isère elle était originaire
de toul en meurthe et moselle la
montagne et dangereux cette année il ya
des plaques de neige qui subsiste en
raison d'un hiver très rigoureux sur des
itinéraires réputé assez facile c'est
bien qu'il faut faire particulièrement
attention cette année sur le massif du
mont-blanc le beau temps est revenu mais
il souffle un vent violent et on est
toujours sans nouvelles de deux
alpinistes italiens qui ont disparu dans
le mont-blanc les alpinistes qui était
bloqué dans le mont-blanc depuis
dimanche dernier au regard ni ont
regagné chamonix qui est sain et sauf
mais deux jeunes étudiants italien
eugenio sousse et paolo martinoni sont
portés manquants
il avait entrepris l'ascension du mont
blanc par l'itinéraire du col de la
brenva on les a vus pour la dernière
fois dimanche vers 17 heures ils étaient
environ il était environ à mi parcours
depuis plus rien ce matin sur le versant
italien l'hélicoptère qui était parti
pour essayer de les retrouver a été
rejetée par les vents par les vents
rabattant avant même d'arriver à la
hauteur du col de la brenva les
recherches sont donc provisoirement
abandonné et on ne garde plus d'espoir
après maintenant quatre jours de
retrouver vivants les deux jeunes gens
voici maintenant le guide italien
alaixys ollier qui a participé aux
recherches interviewé par michel causse
nous avons envoyé deux gendarmes
secouristes sur l'itinéraire de descente
du corridor et d'autre part ils ont fait
une reconnaissance en hélicoptère sur
les prendre la bringue où il
éventuellement il aurait pu redescendre
et nous avons vu également une troisième
possibilité c'est que les ai pu
traverser sur le mont maudit
hélas aucune trace de vie la seule
partie qu'ils n'ont pas vu ces
itinéraires col de la baraque sommet du
mont-blanc sommet du mont blanc refuse
vallot hélas ma foi avec le mauvais
temps actuel ne nous ont rien pu voir il
c'est la seule chance de survie c'est de
le retrouver dans cette zone là
traverser la place de l'étoile en
voiture ce ne sera peut-être plus une
aventure à partir de samedi
en effet le tunnel sous l'arc de
triomphe vient d'être terminé et il va
être ouvert la circulation la place de
l'étoile était la terreur des
automobilistes de province qui venaient
visiter paris à partir de samedi 10h ils
ne risqueront plus d'y laisser une aile
ou un bout de pare chocs
essentielle du problème étant en partie
résolu par la mise en place du
souterrain qui relie en sens unique
l'avenue des champs-elysées à l'avenue
de la grande armée
voici donc ce souterrain tel que nous
l'avons découvert pour 541 mètres de
long 3 180 m 2 sous sol quelques
secondes pour traverser cette place
point noir de la circulation à paris
puisque on y compte environ 200 mille
véhicules par jour avec des pointes de
20 milles à l'heure l'acce
champs-elysées grande armée représente à
lui seul 40% de ce trafic
le souterrain devrait donc absorber près
du tiers du trafic global achevée en 18
mois il comporte et des équipements
techniques perfectionnées l'ingénieur
général bros sein des services
techniques de la ville de paris nous en
parlons maintenant quand il aura une
longueur de 383 m la partie couverte
aura une longueur de 383 m il sera muni
d'un système de ventilation artificielle
en outre il sera également équipé d'une
installation d'éclairage très
perfectionnés et également d'une
installation de surveillance de la
circulation
il y aura un poste de surveillance
permanent de la circulation
équipés de caméras qui permettront aux
agents de service de se rendre compte de
la circulation aux abords et dans le
souterrain
quel est le prix de revient global des
travaux le prix de revient est
actuellement de 29 millions de nos
francs
et là serge rémy aurait été le premier à
passer sous tunnel de l'étoile michel
drucker en sport c'est essentiellement
l'athlétisme qui est oui on vous êtes
actuelle à sétif cela vous donne tout à
l'heure dé l actualité sportif de cette
journée avec deux événements qui se
déroulent aux deux extrémités de
l'europe le match urss usa qui a lieu à
leningrad et les jeux du commonwealth
qui se poursuivent à edimbourg nous en
avons déjà parlé au début de ce journal
aux jeux du commonwealth et thiennot qui
a la vedette depuis deux jours il fait
parler de lui pour deux raisons une
raisons extra-sportives dix classes vous
en a dit un mot des buts de ce journal
mais surtout parce que kenzo a réalisé
trois minutes 36 secondes 6
dixième au cours de la finale du 15
cents mètres de ces jeux du commonwealth
et une bonne performance qui n'a
pourtant pas satisfait le coureur kenyan
qui pensaient faire mieux mais enfin il
avait eu reçu une menace de mort avant
le début de ce quinze 100 m il y avait
de quoi tout de même être déconcentré je
vous rappelle que le record du monde
appartient à l'américain jim ryan avec
trois minutes 33 secondes
un dixième kinova participer maintenant
au 5000 mètres de ces jeux du
commonwealth 3 36 6 sur 15 100 m c'est
un temps qui servira peut-être de base à
l'athlète français jean wadoux qui va
tenter une grande performance sur cette
distance ce soir au stade de colombes
entre voici jean wadoux entre 20h et
20h30 pourquoi cette tentative est bien
parce que le coureur français à
l'intention aurait l'intention
d'abandonner le quinze 100 m pour le
5000 m 5000 m est une distance qui lui
réussit bien puisqu'elle avait réussi
une grande performance 13 minutes 28
secondes au cours du match
france etats unis mais pour en avoir le
coeur net avant de choisir
définitivement wadoux veut faire un
dernier essai sur quinze 100 m car il
n'est pas certain de connaître ses
limites exactes sur cette distance mais
s'ils résistaient ce soir un temps
voisin de celui qui doit il serait bien
sûr très embarrassé michel jazy qui a
une opinion averti en cette matière a
dit ce matin que wadoux peut battre le
record de km nous verrons ça ce soir
nous en parlerons aux cours
d'information première télé soir l'urss
usa c'est un des sommets de la saison
d'athlétisme pourquoi et bien parce que
les deux équipes sont les meilleurs du
monde
raymond mars y avait claude mais dieu
sont à leningrad ils vous feront vivre
les épreuves de cette première journée à
partir de 15h30 cet après midi sur la
première chaîne
nous allons maintenant changer
complètement de sport un boxeur défraie
la chronique depuis plusieurs mois il
est devenu en quelques semaines une des
vedettes de la catégorie des poids
lourds
c'est un basque espagnol il s'appelle
burtin il s'entraîne actuellement à
paris où le xv anglais la rencontre est
effectivement michel drucker josé miguel
hurtin d'hibarette opposé ici à bayonne
au noir américain john son palmarès peu
glorieux jaune sera rapidement battu 44
ans après paolino excuses d'un champion
d'europe des poids lourds yourte 1 est
devenu champion d'europe à 27 ans après
trois saisons de boxe professionnelle à
madrid l'ex lover de pierre babey landes
détenteur du titre et waesland prend une
belle correction
la rencontre est elle sincère
urbain signe sa 28e victoire avant la
limite à barcelone hurtin connaît le
knock down devant son challenger le
blond allemand jürgen boos démontrons un
grand courage hurtin va se relever
infligée à son tour un hot dog à
l'allemand et gagner aux points en
quinze reprises c'est son 29e succès
mais il prouve que sa technique n'est
pas encore parfaite
actuellement il est à paris il
s'entraîne à saint-ouen chez le
professeur je vais tuer
c'était comme une entité hostile aux
nourrissons et 11 kilos ça l'est aussi
josé jover hurtin la carrière qui semble
parfois organisés et ils un champion ou
nous je suis fait très étonné de cette
question parce que vraiment le summum
dit
sa carrière sa carrière et ce qu'elle
aimait et le souvenir si c'est un
champion je me réponds oui parce qu'il
est chopé drap
oui d'accord mais enfin si vous voulez
sur les 28 ko qui l'a obtenu il y a
quand même des cas ou contre des
adversaires faciles
il est évident que lorsqu'un boxeur
débute une carrière on ne peut pas y
prendre des adversaires sont durs il est
évident que go pareil que aux autres
boxeurs eu le temps de chercher comme de
la seule qui soit à s'attaquer soit sa
forme pour que le talent puisse gagner
c'est un peu normal
quelles sont ses défauts quelles sont
ses qualités comme des fous j'ai entendu
le président en défensive c'est un
garçon qui a beaucoup à apprendre qu'en
défensive et ses qualités c'est sa
récupération physique qui est
extraordinaire il approuvait en face du
regain de la demande n'est jamais là
disait fatigué jamais il a dit lutter en
sont les rien c'est un garçon qui a une
récupération vraiment étonnante
étonnante fureteur va vous dire qu'il
veut devenir champion du monde
en vérité le jour le plus long ça veut
dire quelque chose
ah oui ça bien sûr c'est un livre qui a
été énormément lu à travers le monde
le débarquement de normandie en 44 et
l'auteur s'était cogné le ministre aille
en voilà et bien il est à paris en ce
moment et jean l'osi l'a suivi pendant
une journée il eu un peu de mal
d'ailleurs à le suivre
ce fut une véritable course dans paris
sur les pas de cet américain qui veut
vivre ici aussi vite qu aux etats unis
nous avions un gros handicap
cornelius ryan à une ferrari et ses
rendez-vous son ombre quand ils
s'arrêtent quelques heures chez nous
premier rendez vous dans un bistrot du
xviie arrondissement sénat jean
littéraire en france a été sortie de son
bureau par un coup de téléphone quelques
minutes plus tôt mieux vaut la rencontre
et ici c'est une question d'ambiance du
royaume il mène la vie et les affaires
rondement
outre les contrats les traductions les
films il faut trouver le temps de
compulsé les archives d'écrire encore et
de conserver ses amis plein de ceux ci
attend notre auteur place vendôme où il
le connu dans paris en guerre c'est
charles ritz propriétaire de l'hôtel qui
porte son nom
avec lui on parle pêche car monsieur
ritz est l'une des meilleures lignes du
monde entier en matière de pêche
sportive
c'est l'un des hobbies c'est l'une des
manies de cornelius ryan aussi devant
une vieille fine champagne on prend
rendez vous pour une prochaine sortie
l'heure tourne on attend monsieur ryan à
deux pas de la rue de la paix christiane
y habite depuis des années l'auteur
américain qui est classée parmi les 10
hommes les mieux vêtues au monde
cornelius ryan y tiens c'est son
élégance d'être élégant ça c'est très
bien pour le soir le premi mais ces
visites trop rapide n'empêche pas de se
souvenir 26 ans après sa première venue
à paris c'était alors côté d'hemingway
alors que tous deux été correspondant de
guerre c'était la veille de la
libération de paris sur cette même place
vendôme ryan hemingway reporter en
avant-garde une équipe et qui leur
vaudra les réprimandes du commandement
allié
ils avaient précédé les troupes de 24
heures pour me rendre compte de
l'événement pour cornelius ryan
c'était aussi le début d'une carrière
d'écrivain journalistes le jour le plus
long plus de 5 millions d'exemplaires
vendus dans le monde
la bataille de berlin après cela au fait
comment obtient-il les documents qui
sont à la base de ces reconstitutions
c'est un travail qui n'est pas facile
d'abord la rue de saint just à la bonté
de financer une partie du travail de
recherche
il faut ainsi chercher mes archives
anciennes de tous côtés
sa méthode est de montrer comment tout
est arrivé
comment tout a été vue de chaque côté
des belligérants est très difficile vous
avez à utiliser aussi bien des journaux
de l'époque
les archives des divisions des
compagnies texte il faut de 6 à 10 ans
pour écrire l'un de ses ouvrages et
chaque ouvrage tout en recherche à peu
près 400 mille nouveaux francs
ryan croit vraiment sincèrement sa
profession il est d'abord est uniquement
un journaliste après avoir été un
reporter il ne prétend pas être un
hemingway ou tout autre auteur il est
seulement un journaliste et il estime il
lui semble que c'est une très haute
mission
il est très fier si l'on veut un
chroniqueur du temps où vivent oui
d'ailleurs cornelis ryan prépare un
nouveau livre je crois de la même veine
sur la bataille d'arnhem cette fois est
bien 136 30 sans transition pardon je
vous propose la suite de notre petit
feuilleton quotidien sur les collections
hier soir au micro d'information
première coco chanel nous déclarait
qu'il ne fallait pas réduire la mode à
de simples problèmes de longueur et bien
voici maintenant ce que propose
successivement pas tout et ungaro qui
islami a rencontré sur des images de
jean françois etienne et bernard puis
sow lyng souple taille haute longueur à
mi-mollet chez patou michel goba vous
parmi sa collection la ligne cette
collection est rallongé nettement
rallonger la robe ou le manteau se porte
à mi mollet les effets de taille sont
très souvent surélevé l'école en boitant
les tissus sont très souples
il y à pas mal de garniture de fourrure
un grand retour chapeau des grands cols
sur les manteaux mais toujours en forme
de trench coat les couleurs les couleurs
il ya énormément de brun
des noirs mais des rouges lac des jaunes
or et beaucoup de gris mais toujours
très gai et en garnis de cuir ou de
fourrure des gens lettres orient pour le
soir désolé trou et pour le soir pour le
jour aussi qui donne un petit côté russe
beaucoup de tweed et pour le soir
énormément d'imprimer imitant des
matières de sport une nouvelle femme
pour l'hiver emmanuel ungaro
oui une nouvelle femme qui doit être
révolue et et s'intégrer dans dans un
climat un nouveau climat
je crois que c'est une question de
comportement est un problème
d'environnement finalement on a créé du
mois ce point de la longueur à la plèvre
l'invita et j'essaie de dévitaliser ses
poulains de la longueur et la traduire à
travers une très grande féministe et une
très grande douceur et finalement su le
sentiment qui va diriger c'est la
tendresse et lire à plusieurs longueurs
tout de même
oui mais sans que sans que cette
langueur veille dire quelque chose de
très particulier il y aura un départ
canon ce sera anecdotique
ils ont rappelé aux longueurs tout
simplement parce qu'il ya différentes
femmes écrivains longueur doivent perdre
de son importance
et pour le soir des choses très bizarres
très qui paraissent pose des tonalités
très des imprimés très nouveau oui des
fonds très foncée des choses enfin je
crois que c'est dur elle les foulards
sens des couleurs très souvent défaut ce
talent des deux mythes un tout et je ne
sais pas je voudrais que l'on ne sache
pas où les choses commencent et où elles
finissent en fait michel tardieu quelle
est la préoccupation des boursiers
aujourd'hui bien ils n'auront pas d'
excuses pour refuser à leurs femmes la
robe qui leur plaît la séance n'est pas
mauvaise
à condition bien sûr que cette europe de
sopat merci michel tardieu merci à tous
et notre attention bonne journée